[Musique]
merci Philippe houier de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu des Deux Sèvres
membres du groupe les républicains
président de la commission des affaires
sociales ici au Sénat on va longuement
parler du budget de la SCU dont vous
avez débuté l'examen hier mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est cette marche contre
l'antisémitisme à laquelle vous avez
participé dimanche Gérard Larché qui
souhaite que la marche se transforme
désormais en démarche quelle démarche il
faut selon vous je crois que c'est avant
tout un un débat et un dialogue qu'on
doit instaurer sur tout le territoire
national pour sensibiliser nos
concitoyens sensibiliser à tous les
niveaux que ce soit au niveau scolaire
au niveau de la société et puis en même
temps c'est un regard particulier des
forces de l'ordre pour pouvoir sécuriser
ceux qui aujourd'hui se sentent en
difficulté sur notre territoire national
voilà et je crois une prise de
conscience collective que voilà ça nous
rappelle des dépend de notre histoire et
donc il faut qu'on mette tous les moyens
pour combattre cette situation cette
marche le succès de cette marche he il y
a eu quasiment 200000 personnes qui ont
marché dimanche ça c'est l'illustration
d'une prise de conscience collective
pour vous oui je le pense je crois que
on avait finalement toutes les
sensibilité politique globalement qui
étit présente on avait des acteurs de la
vie publique on avait ass de
personnalités et puis des des des
inconnus qui se sont mobilisé donc cette
marche qui été quand même assez
improvisée mais d'ailleurs je salue
l'initiative de nos deux présidents
d'assemblée finalement éit une réussite
le tout maintenant c'est que ça s'arrête
pas simplement un événement dimanche
dernier c'est comment et bien au
quotidien et dans tous les départs r
dans tous les départements ce type
d'initiative a été organisé comment
est-ce qu'on arrive à sensibiliser
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens il y avait
un absent notamment c'était le président
de la République elle est regrettable
cette absence pour vous elle est
regrettable après il il a ses raisons
voilà je crois que je pas je pas rentrer
dans la polémique il a porté un message
qui est parfois un peu ambigu B
globalement on voit bien qu'il une
mobilisation de tous les acteurs compris
des membres du gouvernement dit que
c'est une faute vous dites pas la même
chose je peut-être un terme moins fort
en tous les cas sa non présence marqué
l'actualité au Sénat cet après-midi il y
a le le budget de la SCU mais il y a
aussi le vote du projet de loi
immigration qui aura lieu dans une
version durci par le Sénat qualifié je
cite d'indigne et truffé de préjugés
racistes par les parlementaires de
gauche qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez
bah je crois que ils sont sur leur ligne
politique nous la ligne celle du Sénat
elle était connue on sait qu'aujourd'hui
on a une vraie volonté de répondre une
attente forte des Français qui est
comment est-ce qu'on limite
l'immigration irrégulière et donc à
partir de là on a eu un outil juridique
législative qui nous permet de
finalement mettre nos marqueurs des
marqueurs qui sont connus reconnus voilà
donc je crois que je comprends la
réaction de la gauche et pas dans sa
culture mais on voit le résultat aussi
hein de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
donc je crois que le Sénat et que la
droite parlementaire a pris ses
responsabilités sur un texte pas facile
à porter mais quelque part nous avons
joué notre rôle de législateur parmi les
les mesures votées par qui vont être
votées par le Sénat on l'a vu dans le
sujet de jom il a la suppression de la
me l'aide médicale d'État qui est
remplacé par une aide médicale d'urgence
c'est c'est-à-dire un panier de soins
réduit plus de 3500 professionnels de
santé ont signé une déclaration de
désobéissance dans laquelle il s'eng ils
s'engageent à continuer de soigner
gratuitement les patients sans papier
selon leur besoins qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez alors cette réaction on peut on
peut l'entendre vis-à-vis de
professionnel de santé mais en même
temps c'est avant tout des militants qui
qui qui qui qui s'impliquent moi
d'ailleurs je connais une un des
signataires qui est d'abord contre le
texte de loi avant d'évoquer le sujet de
la me et ça c'est important de le
rappeler et ça correspond à moins de 1 %
des professionnels je comprends parce
que si on est uniquement sur la question
de dire est-ce que aujourd'hui vous
allez soigner ou pas quelqu'un je
comprends que un professionnel dit moi
j'ai un serment je dois le faire faut
être clair Laamu aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas la fin des soins il y a un pan soins
qui est peut-être limité mais on gère
les urgences on gère la prévention
notamment j'ai entendu des des remarques
sur problème de de risque on regarde la
vaccination je crois qu'aujourd'hui il y
a une responsabilité qui est prise moi
lorsque je lis le rapport de l'Office
français de de l'Immigration de
l'Intégration je vois clair écrit que le
l'aspect l'accès au soin et bien créer
aujourd'hui un appel d'air pour une
certaine catégorie de personnes qui sont
en citation régulière c'est écrit on
voit bien notamment sur les soins les
plus onéreux ou tout ce qui est la
partie innovation donc il faut trouver
un juste équilibre on doit prendre en
considération la santé des personnes en
situation régulière et en même temps et
bien il faut avoir cette cette liste de
mesures pour limiter rappelons quand
même que c'est uniquement le débat du
remboursement un professionnel de santé
peut he parce que j'ai j'ai lu un peu
partout que on on ne soignerait pas les
gens non non le débat c'est la prise en
charge alors entre l'urgence et la
notion en même temps de de prévention je
crois que on a quand même une vraie
possibilité d'intervenir pour vous c'est
une ligne rouge ou ça peut faire partie
d'un compromis entre députés et sénateur
un point sur lequel vous pourriez céder
alors pour moi c'est pas forcément une
ligne rouge c'est un point important
d'ailleurs au sén on est fidèle he tous
les ans et encore cette année nous faons
la mise en place de l'AMU voilà donc
c'est pour moi c'est pas forcément une
ligne rouge mais ça fait partie à mon
avis des des points importants et donc
on verra la négociation sur lequel il
faut à un moment donné qu'on a une
position ferme ça a très bien été dit
dans le reportage ouais et on a entendu
he Bruno retaillot dire que si le
l'assemblée détricoter le texte du Sénat
il appeléit les députés LR à déposer une
motion de censure et à la voté est-ce
que vous êtes vraiment en capacité les
LR de faire tomber le gouvernement je
crois que d'abord on est avant tout dans
un bras de fer pour montrer l'importance
du pour pour le groupe LR de ce texte de
loi et et quelque part l'importance pour
les français pour pour l'avenir de notre
de territoire national après les je
politique je pense que s'il y a toute
l'alliance des oppositions le
gouvernement tombe voilà alors est-ce
que SAF que la gauche veut pas voter
avec vous voilà nous verrons parce que
voilà donc ils veulent voter avec nous
quand ça les arrange voilà donc
attendons de voir mais je crois que
surtout ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
c'est un débat de responsabilité sur un
texte qui est pas facile he
politiquement qui est pas facile sur le
terrain il faut beaucoup de pédagogie
pour expliquer et je crois que là la
droite et LR prend ses responsabilités
on va parler de l'autre actu au Sénat
cet après mais c'est la suite du budget
de la sécurité sociale vous avez
commencé l'examen hier après-midi on va
faire le point avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Quentin
[Musique]
calmer bonjour Quentin bonjour Oran
bonjour bonjour et Quentin le Sénat
s'est donc emparé hier du budget de la
Sécurité sociale dans un contexte
politique particulier oui ça signe le
début du marathon Bud budgétaire comme
chaque automne au Parlement c'est
effectivement le budget de la santé des
Fran français qui éta examiné en premier
et ce projet de loi qui a effectivement
été adopté par 493 à l'Assemblée
nationale cela signifie concrètement que
c'est la copie du gouvernement que vous
avez reçu et que le gouvernement a sans
doute recours à nouveau à 493 à la fin
de la procédure parlementaire c'est à la
fois une bonne et une mauvaise chose
pour les sénateurs parce que le débat va
avoir lieu dans son intégralité ici à la
Chambre du Parlement il y a pas de 493
ici au Sénat mais cela signifie aussi
que le gouvernement pourrait conserver à
la fin ce qu'il souhaite dans la copie
du texte comment est-ce que vous
appréhendez tout d'abord ce contexte de
l'examen du PLFSS alors vous l'avez très
bien dit finalement le seul espace de
débat de dialogue il va se dérouler au
Sénat donc on a une responsabilité pour
porter un certain nombre de message
d'orientation et donc dans cette
discussion avec le gouvernement après
c'est le 493 donc c'est vrai que le
gouvernement peut trancher et garder sa
copie mais c'était déjà un peu le cas
lorsqu'il était majoritaire à
l'Assemblée nationale il pouvait
conserver sa copie ce que je constate
avec un peu d'expérience depuis 9 ans
c'est que à chaque fois que que nous
débattons à chaque fois nous faons un
certain nombre de propositions et bien
il reste un certain nombre d'éléments
dans le texte final parce que au-delà de
la dimension politique et peut-être
chiffre on en parlera c'est aussi
parfois un peu de bon sens dans la
pratique et donc on arrive à voir un
certain nombre d'avancé même si c'est
avant tout pour nous des marqueurs
notamment sur l'équilibre des comptes
sociaux mais quel quel quel message du
coup quel message politique vous voulez
faire passer et est-ce que vous pouvez
faire autre chose que passer un message
politique alors déjà le message
politique c'est important après dans le
détail on peut passer d'autres éléments
je crois que le message politique a été
très clair hier on l'a vu au moment de
la discussion générale aujourd'hui on
est surtout nous inquiet de la façon de
la méthode utilisée par le gouvernement
le gouvernement donc nous annonce un
déficite important plus de 11 milliards
pour cette année on vient de 8,8
milliards et avec une tendance jusqu'en
2027 pour arriver jusqu'à 17,5 milliard
c'est-à-dire que globalement il inscrit
dans la loi le principe général de dire
et bien la sécurité sociale et bien va
être en difficulté dans la durée donc ça
c'est un message sur lequel on souhaite
réagir naturellement vous nous faites
une très belle transition et ben oui
puisque le gouvernement a présenté les
tendances pour le budget de la SQ et ces
tendances sont inquiétantes selon les
sénateurs voilà ce qu'on appelle
communément le trou de la SQ il se
creuse le déficit est estimé à 8,8
milliards d'euros en 2023 mais aussi à
11,2 milliards en 2024 17,5 milliards
d'euros en 2025 alors dans ce contexte
le gouvernement lui il se félicite tout
de même de réaliser 3,5 milliards
d'euros d'économie dans les dépenses de
l'assurance maladie écoutez le ministre
des compes public c'était donc hier lors
de la discussion générale qui a ouvert
l'examen de ce texte nous ne pouvons pas
fermer les yeux sur la question
financière car nous risquerions
d'hypothéquer notre capacité à faire
face aux crises de demain si nous avons
réussi à mettre en œuvre le quoi qu'il
en coûte et à protéger les Français face
à la crise sanitaire c'est parce que
nous avions des marges de suffisante il
faut les retrouver mais pour les
sénateurs les prévisions de recette du
gouvernement seraient en plus surestimé
cela est inquiétant écoutez la
rapporteur générale du budget Elisabeth
doanau hier en séance il y a là comme un
aveu d'impuissance l'idée assumée que
l'on transmet aux générations futures la
dette sociale schématiquement la branche
maladie actuellement déficitaire
d'environ 10 milliards d'euros le
resterait jusqu'en
2027 alors que dire de cette trajectoire
Philippe mouill on a vu les chiffres
sont-ils inquiétants ils sont
inquiétants et et au-delà des chiffres
on constate finalement que pfss après
pfss on consacre plus de moyens
financiers à la santé des français alors
que avec un un trou de la Sécu qui
augmente alors que l'accès au soins la
qualité des soins est en diminution et
que les professionnels de santé sont
aujourd'hui en grande difficulté donc
vous aimz le principe on met plus de
moyens pour un résultat qui est moins
bon dans la durée et donc donc
aujourd'hui on alerte en se disant on
peut pas continuer parce que finalement
on est dans une spirale et d'ailleurs
c'est la première fois que le
gouvernement inscrit dans la loi le
principe de dire et ben finalement la
dette perpétuelle pour nos enfants on en
cons comme étant un principe de gestion
et donc ça on peut pas l'accepter donc
c'est le message qu'on va porter
d'ailleurs la question c'est comment
est-ce qu'on ferait d'ailleurs voilà et
donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a un
certain nombre de propositions que nous
serons Amir comment vous l'expliquez
qu'on met plus d'argent et qu'il a moins
de soin parce que on change on réforme
rien
c'estdur structurel bien sûr vous avez
un gouvernement qui aujourd'hui ne porte
aucun texte de loi structurant sur la
santé ou la dépendance simplement on
vote des propositions de loi des PPL
c'est que le gouvernement n'assume même
pas cette responsabilité on vote des PPL
où on fait des mesures des mesures sans
prendre en compte une vision globale
s'il n'y a pas de réforme nous
continuons ce principe là d'argent
supplémentaire pour un résultat attendu
moins bon alors justement quand comment
le texte va évoluer dans les prochains
jours alors les sénateurs on va voir
quelquesunes de vos propositions qui
vont être examinées en séance vous
voulez déjà le report de la réforme de
la tarification à l'activité c'est ce
qu'on appelle communément la T2A vous
voulez ça à en 2028 après une
expérimentation autre mesure la
consultation du Parlement en cas
d'augmentation des franchises médicales
parce que c'est de l'ordre du
réglementaire le gouvernement pourrait
donc le prendre la décision seul vous
voulez qu'il a d'abord un débat au
Parlement si c'est franchises médical
devait bouger et on voit une autre
proposition une taxe lapin si vous voilà
si vous ne vous présentez pas un
rendez-vous médical et bien dans ce
cas-là vous aurez quelque chose à payer
autre modification on continue qui
devrait avoir lieu en séance les
sénateurs ne veulent pas de la vente de
médicamentens à l'unité quant au
médicaments à base de cannabis vous
demandez l'avis de la Haute Autorité de
santé avant de le permettre pourquoi
être aussi prudent sur le premier point
que j'ai évoquer la réforme de la
tarification à l'acte pour la gauche
c'est une des seules avancées dans ce
projet de loi alors on est plutôt
favorable à cette modification de la
tarification mais de nouveau on a un
problème de méthode on change les règles
de tarification et de financement des
des établissements de santé sans avoir
revu l'organisation ça veut dire que on
est en train de dire quoi on veut plutôt
une expérimentation pendant 3 ans de
façon à ce que le gouvernement puisse
réellement et bien avoir une application
adaptée au besoins des établissements
avant la généralisation
et donc voilà donc c'est quelque part
une bonne idée que l'on soutient
d'ailleurs dans nos rapports nous avons
évoqué le besoin de compléter avec des
dotations mais de nouveau on a un
problème de méthode alors c'est vrai
pour la T2A mais c'est vrai également
pour certain nombre d'expérimentations
qui sont qui enfin qui sont proposé
notamment dans les relations avec les
départements pour lequel nous souhaitons
qu'il ait avant tout une phase d'cès
c'est la fusion des des sections soins
et dépendance pour les épades voilà donc
on est de nouveau sur le problème de la
méthode c'estàdire que le ministre même
nous explique en mission que cette
béthode n'est pas complètement abouti
que en matière budgétaire on
fonctionnera en enveloppe constante donc
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on est
encore dans une phase d'essès donc on
considère que la prudence et la sagesse
c'est l'essais soit porté par une
expérimentation avant une généralisation
sur la question des franchises médicales
c'est ce qui reste à à l'assurer he
quand il achète un médicament ou quand
il va chez le médecin le gouvernement un
temps avait envisagé de les augmenter
aujourd'hui c'est plus flou on on sait
pas vraiment le gouvernement n'a pas
tranché est-ce que pour vous il faut les
augmenter alors moi je suis plutôt
favorable sur la responsabilité
globalement des patients mais voyez de
nouveau le gouvernement nous fait un
annonce en disant la franchise médicale
avec une recette attendue entre 800 et
900 millions d'euros ça disparaît au
moment du pfss par contre dans les
prévisions d'économie de 3,5 milliards
c'est toujours présent donc ce n'est
plus dans le texte mais c'est dans les
chiffres donc on échange quoi on dit à
momentné il y a un problème de sérieux
il y a un problème de sincérité d'où
l'amendement qui demande au gouvernement
de revenir devant les commissions d'
affffaires sociales de façon à débattre
de ce point-là toujours un débat de
transparence et de méthode est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi vous
allez rejeter longam longam qui est
l'objectif des dépenses notamment en
milieu hospitalier vous pouvez nous
expliquer vous allez rejeter cette
partie du texte très simplement pourquoi
parce que de nouveau comme l'ann
dernière on constate deux choses un long
d'AM aujourd'hui et les dépenses de
longam sont sous-estimées d'ailleurs la
preuve on est en train de discuter du
budget pendant que les négociations
conventionnelles avec les médecins vont
s'ouvrir avec une traduction budgétaire
donc on voit bien que en matière de
dépense longame aujourd'hui est
insincère et en plus il est insuffisant
dans certaines parties de donc notamment
de l'organisation de la santé pendant ce
temps-là c'était très bien dit dans le
rapportage les recettes attendues nous
semblent aussi également surestimé donc
on sait avant même que voter on dame que
le long dame est un L dame qui sera
trompé c'est un L dame qui correspond
pas à la réalité donc notre
responsabilité clairement aujourd'hui de
dire à un moment donné de nouveau il
faut mettre les vrais chiffres sur la
table et organiser autrement la la la G
la santé finalement il y a un autre
point qui reste un peu flou de la part
du gouvernement c'est la ponction de
laag Carco qui avait été un temps
envisagé là aussi c'est le régime de
retraite du privé ponction pour financer
le régime de retraite générale que doit
faire le gouvernement là-dessus alors
clairement il doit nous écouter c'està-d
quoi c'estàdire que nous on est
respectueux du paréarisme donc on
souhaite que cette possibilité soit à la
main finalement des partenaires sociaux
de soutien ou non exactement qui gère
les à la fois pour AG carcoou mais
également pour l'unidic voilà donc un
moment moment donné le gouvernement ne
peut pas venir faire les poches des
caisses des ceux qui ont su bien gérer
finalement les retraites et donc c'est
avant tout un dialogue c'est le respect
du paréarisme j'ai une dernière question
très rapide mais ce qu'on comprend c'est
qu'il manque une grande loi santé non
visiblement le gouvernement à chaque
fois vous faites des propositions vous
dit il faut queon ait ce débat là lors
du projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale et là vous dites que
vous avez les mains liées par ce texte
et qu'il manque une grande loi santé
dans ce pays complètement il manque une
grande loi de santé il manque une grande
loi dépendance c'est le finalement le le
le on devrait débuter par ça et ensuite
on le traduirait dans le pfss mais de
nouveau retenez le principe sans le
grand noix de santé on met plus d'argent
pour une qualité des soins qui est en
diminution un accès au soins qui est
plus compliqué et des professionnels de
santé qui sont en souffrance je crois
que le le constat est plutôt alarmant
justement sur la question de l'accès au
soins il y a des médecins qui fent à la
non hausse du tarif des consultation se
déconventionne c'est-à-dire que les
patients ne sont plus remboursés
lorsqu'il les consultent est-ce que vous
êtes contre ce déconvotionnement ou
est-ce que vous comprenez les médecins
qui voient leur tarifs qui n'augmentent
pas depuis des années alors je le
regrette mais je le comprends et je
pense que c'est pas qu'un problème de
tarif le tarif est un enjeu important on
le voit bien mais c'est aussi un un
enjeu de relation avec l'administration
aujourd'hui beaucoup de médecins
souffrent finalement d'une
bureaucratisation de leur métier de
contrôle permanent et puis en même temps
ils sont souvent seuls sur les
territoires et donc ils sont eux-mêmes
en souffrance je dirais dans leur dans
le activité professionnelle donc c'est
un ensemble de d'éléments sur lequels il
faut être conscient et donc les
conventions qui s'ouvrent devront
devront tenir compte de ces éléments là
Quentin une question parce que vous avez
beaucoup travaillé sur l'étude des des
mères ruraux dont dont on va parler tout
à l'heure et qui montre qu'il y a une
fracture territoriale effectivement on
va en parler dans dans dans le club des
territoires tout à l'heure mais c'est
une une une étude qui a été publiée hier
par l'association des des villes
effectivement rurales on voit que
l'accès au milieu hospitalier est bien
différent en milieu rural qu'en milieu
urbain on pouvait s'en douter mais c'est
démontrer la distance en fait
géographique fait que les Français en
milieu rural sont moins bien soignés
avec des conséquences importantes pour
leur santé qu'est-ce que cette étude
vous a inspiré ben je crois que elle n'y
a que confirmer ce que nous imaginions
et puis d'autres études avec un impact
d'ailleurs aussi sur l'espérance de vie
hein clairement hein voilà et partir
rural il perd 2 ans d'espérance de c'est
encore une traduction de ce que je viens
d'évoquer c'est-à-dire que sans réforme
structurelle qui part de la formation de
l'organisation de l'installation et bien
nous continuerons dans ce système à deux
vitesses à deux vitesse territoriale
géographique de de vitesses au niveau
social et donc on voit aujourd'hui qu'il
y a une urgence pour lequel l'expression
des m eururos est importante mais il y a
pas que ce sujetl voilà donc on voit
bien qu'aujourd'hui la France fonctionne
à deux vitesses on est aujourd'hui dans
une médecine à deux vitesses clairement
oui je le pense avec d'un côté une
financiarisation un désaccès beaucoup
plus difficile et et que on voit bien
que cette pente n'est pas bonne et donc
il faut réagir il y a vraiment urgence
que d'une réaction du gouvernement c'est
vraiment le message qu'on souhaite
porter au moment de ce pfss c'est pas
qu'un enjeu financier mais de toute
façon on réglera rien par l'argent si on
réorganise pas les choses merci Quentin
à tout à l'heure voilà tout à l'heure on
va reparler effectivement de cette étude
sur l'accès aux soins en milieu rural ce
sera évidemment à suivre dans le club on
va voir l'actualité dans nos régions on
va aller du côté de la Corse d'Ajaccio
bonjour Henry Marianne merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous directeur délégué de
Corse ce matin et hier cor ce matin
publié une enquête à la fois
passionnante et surprenante sur le
recours à l'IVG sur l'île qu'est-ce
qu'on y
apprend alors on est parti en fait du du
discours du chef de l'État devant le le
Conseil constitutionnel début octobre
qui demandait au parlementaire de de
Hatter un peu le pas afin d'inscrire
l'IVG dans dans la Constitution elle est
allée un peu à la pêche aux infos c'est
laticia janekin qui s'est emparé de de
ce sujet pour voir un peu quels étaient
les chiffres de l'IVG encore si on était
auudessus de la moyenne nationale dans
la moyenne en dessous et les chiffres
sont assez surprenants on a appris et en
lisant cor ce matin vous l'avez
peut-être appris vous aussi qu'il y
avait en gros entre 1000 et 1200 IVG en
Corse par an alors ramener à une
population de 300000 habitants c'est peu
mais si on fait le ratio ça fait à peu
près un taux de 17,5 IVG par an pour
1000 femmes et la moyenne nationale est
à 15 donc vous voyez qu'on est quand
même de points 2 points et demi presque
trois points auudessus de la la moyenne
nationale et c'est ce que ce que dit un
peu ce cet article cette enquête et qui
décrypte un peu les les mécanismes de de
ces chiffres et Henry vous avez une
question pour le sénateur Philippe
Mouillet oui monsieur le sénateur je
faisais référence au discours du du chef
de l'État devant le Conseil
constitutionnel qui demande aux
parlementaires de se dépêcher un peu
afin d'inscrire l'IVG dans la
Constitution pourquoi faut-il
sanctuariser l'IVG dans la dans la
Constitution parce que c'est une façon
de se prémunir de de de de l'arrivée de
certains partis politiques au au pouvoir
qui qui contestent l'IVG qui sont contre
qui sont opposés moi moi je je suis pas
certain que ça soit aujourd'hui une
urgence d'ailleurs on le voit le nombre
d'IVG en France est en augmentation en
cor particulièrement mais globalement ça
fonctionne plutôt bien et l'accès
s'améliore même si c'est parfois
compliqué voilà à partir de là si le
texte vient au Sénat jeis parti de ceux
qui le voteront sur la
constitutionnalisation d'vg je veux dis
aujourd'hui la Constitution logiquement
il faut quand même être dans un état
avançon plus PL plutôt plutôt limité
voilà je crois que le vrai sujet pour
moi c'est beaucoup plus les conditions
d'accès à l'IVG c'est beaucoup plus la
capacité d'accompagnement des femmes
dans ce type d'intervention qui qui a
aussi un impact et physique et
psychologique que le débat de la
constitutionnalisation si débat vient au
Sénat je vous dis je le voterai ou vous
le voez mais c'est peut-être pas le cas
de l'ensemble de votre groupe c'est même
sûrement pas le cas de l'ensemble de
votre groupe est-ce est-ce que ça va
fortement vous diviser non enfin je
pense que je je sais pas si ça va
vraiment nous diviser parce que d'une
façon gén général très très très grande
majorité des membres de mon groupe sont
favorables à l'vg je croyais même pas de
débat le vraie question son favoraable à
son inscription question c'est est-ce
qu'on met dans la Constitution bon voilà
bon à partir de là si ça doit protéger
je suis pas sûr que ça soit utile si
globalement ça doit rassurer si ça doit
être un message politique fort on
l'accompagnera mais je suis très prudent
et dans cette maison qui qui connaît
bien finalement le fonctionnement des
lois de la République on est toujours
très puudent dans la modification de la
Constitution
Henri bah dit quand même un certain
nombre de choses quand on regarde les
chiffres cors on se rend compte et quand
on on interroge les les médecins les
praticiens on se rend compte surtout que
l'IVG elle est elle est pratiquée par
par des par des jeunes femmes parce
qu'elles ont peur de l'avenir pas de
travail les conséquences économiques
l'inflation c'est ce qui ressort dans
l'article que l'on a publié dans dansc
ce matin et en fait c'est c'est un
phénomène de société qui vient un peu
percuter la situation économique et la
peur de de de l'avenir c'est un peu ça
non c'est quand même oui jeends ce que
disent ces chiffres ouis mais ça renvoit
aussi un vrai sujet que nous devons
porter notamment au moment du budget
c'est le débat de not politique en
matière de la natalité c'est un point
important c'est vous l'avez très bien
dit la traduction face à l'inquiétude
d'un ce nombre de femmes avec l'action
pour pour les VG c'est aussi parce qu'à
un moment donné on ne répond pas au
niveau national aux préoccupations
comment est- qu'on accompagne les coupes
pour le premier enfant comment on
intervient auprès des parents isolés
comment voilà on a aussi clairement une
respons habilité politique en matière de
natalité et qui aura forcément un impact
sur le débat sur
l'IVG merci Henry merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous on regarde la Une de cors
matin d'aujourd'hui posidonie côte
d'alerte dans le port de centouri c'est
à la Une de Corse Matin merci beaucoup
Henry Mariane d'avoir été avec nous pour
nous parler de ce sujet merci Philippe
Mouillet merci d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure on
suivra bien sûr dans cette émission la
suite de l'examen du budget de la
Sécurité sociale vous reprenez le texte
cet après-midi jusque tard dans la nuit
merci merci Philippe mouill d'avoir été
notre invité